my hello I didn't see you there
get out we know what's making them guys
play again welcome to channel awesome
the YouTube channel where you can watch
me as the nostalgia critic reviewing
anything and everything relating to your
nostalgia but it's so much more than
watching me at the nostalgia critic you
can watch me as shifter a bum on bum
reviews Dominic on videogame concessions
and my most challenging character Doug
Walker in various sketches be logs and
review shows if you don't like watching
my face though I pity you but also
recommend a bad variety of other shows
that we have including ones that
sometimes have my face in it so you
won't have to panic too much or if you
want to check out even more people you
can check out channel awesome com home
to some great reviewers and comedic
talents that are not me but for not
being me they're pretty good so stick
around and find what you enjoy all are
welcomed here especially the elephants
they're flying around my face what it is
this shit
[Music]